thousands of anti-globalization
protesters are demanding world leaders
in Hamburg get out of town
some of them fought with police last
night and again this morning injuring
dozens of officers First Lady Melania
Trump cannot leave her hotel this
morning because of the demonstrations
Margaret Brennan is also in Hamburg
watching these protests Margaret good
morning to you good morning the future
of free trade and damage to the
environment are contentious topics at
the g20 and it's anger over some of
those very same issues that brought
left-wing activists into the streets of
Hamburg German authorities tried to
prevent protesters from disrupting a g20
summit as it got underway this morning
police dressed in riot gear forcibly
removed several demonstrators staging a
sit-in to block the arrival of world
leaders emergency crews rushed to put
out several cars that were set on fire
as plumes of black smoke filled the
city's skyline
demonstration German American activist
Emily liqueur helped organize the
protest these protests are against the
violence of the g20 we believe that
there is no hope coming from the g20 we
want the American people to know that
Donald Trump has no friends here and
that and when we when Donald Trump comes
to Germany for his first visit to
Germany there will be a massive
opposition Lacour and her fellow
left-wing activists hold g20 leaders
responsible for a first of problems
including climate change the migration
crisis and economic inequality their
blockades caused mayhem Thursday as
police used water cannons on
to break up the crowds the clashes at
times turned violent with demonstrators
set fires and lobbed projectiles German
authorities reported injuries to more
than a hundred officers and more than a
dozen protesters isle insan'
international summits like this or
nothing new police used force to break
up protests during this year's g7 summit
in sicily and during the g20 in Toronto
the activists we spoke with consider
their disruptions a success and they
expect thousands of protesters on the
streets tomorrow when President Trump
and other world leaders depart Nora all
right Margaret Brennan there in Hamburg
thank you so much